this whole thing with Dubai right Dubai
Emirates suspends flights to several U.S
destinations on 5G concerns uh this is a
Reuters Story the move is due to
operational concerns associated with the
plan developing a 5G mobile network
services and the US the company said
that it the destinations include Boston
Chicago Dallas Fort Worth Houston Miami
Newark Orlando San Francisco and Seattle
we are working closely with aircraft
manufacturers and there are relevant
authorities to alleviate operational
concerns and we hope to resume our U.S
Services as soon as possible the carrier
said the White House said earlier on
Tuesday that it wants to reach a
solution on 5G development that protects
air safety while minimizing uh
disruption to our travel how much of
this really is 5G how much of it is
protecting a different messaging that's
happening behind closed doors with
traveling with vaccination cards how
much of it is you know what do you think
the story lies John I'm going to go to
you first
I don't I can't answer any of those
questions is is it's fear porn again
it's Y2K the planes are going to crash
but isn't 5G already in use yeah
and the airlines are already crashing
the major U.S airlines have already told
the FAA no
they told them no about what
about shutting down right exactly
meaning what though they're going to
shut down flights
they're not going to they're no the
American the American big American
Airlines the FAA was like we got to
figure this 5G thing out and it's you
know it's scrambling it's not safe for
you to be in the sky and American
Airlines were like not American Airlines
itself but big American airline
companies
played this video because you know
Tyler's got this video that he wants a
show with 5G again folks this is just a
video I don't want you to lose your mind
it's just a video title found go ahead
so and then the caption here is the FAA
published 1400 plus notices to Airmen
about 5G and International Airlines they
were canceling flights they warned
Pilots not to use their radio altimeter
at more than 80 airports in the U.S it
just drives the gauges Wild
yeah I mean that scrambles him but if
you're assuming the pilot can't fly the
plane and that they won't adjust to this
well he can't fly the plane if he
doesn't have his gauges and he doesn't
know where he's at in his altitude and
whether he's not if he's straight and
level if he's in a bank etc etc etc then
why haven't we seen planes come down
yeah how do I know that's just not a
faulty radar that's just something that
how do I know that's because you're
right David that's why I said you know
this is just a video that title found
online that's showing that uh let me
throw some stats your way because 20
major air um airports have basically
created a buffer zone all the major
airports in uh New York La Miami Orlando
uh DFW and Dallas
um Seattle Philly I mean there's 20
airports that said you cannot have 5G
Within
uh two miles of our airport okay and if
I'm not the 5G expert oh they can't stop
it I don't know but you can't have
Towers yeah yeah you're restricted
exactly but basically where where it
comes into play is not so much when
they're flying around the sky and
they're you know 10 miles up in the air
it's regarding the landings it's when
they're closer within a thousand feet of
the tower is what they're worried about
and then the airlines of the pilot
unions which are not exactly always
seeing eye to eye they're actually
lockstep on that's on the same page
they're basically 100 agreeant that this
is basically
um something that they need to be very
weary of because essentially this comes
down to safety yeah over speed I mean
what's the point of 5G it's basically
these you know cell phone companies are
basically putting up 5G so you can
download your porn even quicker or
communicate even quicker not you John
obviously not you but it's safety and
speed and you know I think right now
we're doing pretty good with the 4G with
the speed uh the 5G is going to make it
10 times 100 times faster but but look
we've got a pretty good happy medium of
protecting the airspace in the immediate
vicinity of the airport then okay
yeah well we've got a very good record
of safety and on our I don't think any
major U.S airline has crashed in the
last decade even longer U.S airlines
domestically 100 so safety is a major
concern I mean people get scared if
there's you know some turbulence on a
plane now if there's a plane that flies
Off The Runway God forbid the Hudson
type things happens again
you know so it's a it's a safety thing
I'm not the 5G expert but basically when
you see the Airlines and the pilot
unions basically on the same page that
should be a Telltale sign that they're
very concerned about this and then
there's and then we've found a solution
what's the solution the buffer zone yeah
okay
I mean I I've had 5G on my phone all
over the country for the past few months
I I looked at it I'm like I'm I'm on 5G
right now okay do you have strong
feelings about this 5G Pat but I doubt I
bet when I'm close to the airport this
afternoon when I'm headed back to DFW
that the 5G disappears
I I don't know you go to these doctors
and they say do you have a lot of
headaches I do do you wear the ear Apple
uh what do you call your earbuds like I
do well we're getting a lot of people
that are coming here saying they get a
lot of headaches from wearing that you
may want to stop wearing that because of
you know whatever radiation they're
talking I'm like okay is there 100 there
I don't know they've been talking about
stuff like this for a long time they
would talk about if you live near Towers
cancer increases I mean and it never has
proven sure that's that's what you said
earlier so
um I think we got to get a good
investigative journalist I think we know
one that can go out there to these
places
he plays way too much volleyball it's
problematic so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]